she is a supermodel for a reason iman a
true golden goddess at the met gala the
66 year old mixed and definitely matched
her harris reed for dolce gabbana
pantsuit complete with a tiered feather
skirt and a massive headdress it was a
wow moment on the carpet because yes the
drama is in the details and the stars
came to spill
all the style tea
i'm here for the first time i'm so
excited i'm ready to see everybody i'm
ready for everybody to see me
yada yada you are bringing me the drama
tonight
yes i am
it takes five gentlemen to turn that
gown of yours
no it took 100 people over 6 600 hours
to make simone swarovski crystal
encrusted gown which didn't get finished
until around 4 a.m sunday
jennifer
j hud who just turned 40 was one of the
night's ladies in bread her curved
hugging number had a 10-foot cake in the
category of new jew who dis arena shake
unrecognizable after chopping several
inches it's about no makeup and fun air
and here we go
let me see those teeth young man
oh my god tonight i feel like a vampire
cowboy
thing and then there's singer kim petrus
who's getting the nickname horse girl
for her look pam
o-m-g i'm wearing colleen estrada and
she grew up in with horse competitions
and so
she made me a horse
some other head scratching accessories
frank ocean carried a green robot baby
yes it moves that some compared to shrek
model hunter schaefer had a spider on
her nose and all white contacts and
grimes was ready for battle with a six
pound sword this is made out of them
it was the mess again oh my god
i think it's my favorite look ever
you